Hello everyone, this is Frank Defradis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of December 13th, 1999.
I have a request that I'd like to make to the HoloTalk listeners and uh had something happen here in the studio uh within the last week.
You'll notice that uh my annual Santa show that I put up uh for everyone out there who has kids or just like Santa on on their own as adults, uh I do that on Holo Talk for one week each year.
Um it's been up for two weeks, and there's a reason for that, and the reason is that I accidentally trashed every HoloTalk show that I've done for this year so far.
They are gone.
I do not have any of the shows.
Uh in fact, the show that I had to go up that week was actually in the folder and that was trashed as well, and I realize I can't get that one back.
But what I'm wondering is, is there anyone out there who not only just listens to HoloTalk but actually downloads the show and perhaps puts the show into a folder and keeps the past Holo Talk shows.
If you are out there, would you please email me and let me know if you have any shows from the past season since we started uh right after Labor Day.
And uh let me know what shows you have.
If you just have one show, uh I'll take one show.
If you have a bunch of shows, I'll take a bunch of shows.
But uh send me an email and let me know if you have any shows that you could attach to an email and send to me.
I'd like to get the archive page up.
In fact, that's how I found out that they were missing was I was beginning to add this year's show onto uh the archive page and um I had no folder.
In the past I've put everything on zip discs.
Uh the past two years I have the uh complete collection on zip discs, but for some reason this year since I started up in September I would just take a show and store it in one of the folders on the hard drive.
Um I have absolutely no idea how I took this folder and just trashed it and it's gone and I what's really strange is I have Norton Utilities that uh file saver which uh can allow you to go back in and retrieve the files but when I do any multimedia production on the machine I disable that which is fine because you can turn it back on after you're finished with the multimedia production uh and it doesn't use any resources um uh for regular thing for regular everyday use of the computer.
Uh but it does tie up resources and processing power um uh when you have uh multimedia production going on so I usually disable it.
So I did not re enable it after I did some multimedia production and uh when I trashed it it wasn't registered by a file saver so I had no way of going back in and possibly uh extracting any of the files off of the hard drive that's there.
So uh if you have one of the past HoloTalk shows I would appreciate it even if it's just one show uh maybe there's a number of you who have different shows that you liked and you kept could you send me an email and let me know and uh we'll get those past shows back up.
So needless to say this week is just myself and I'll be starting up guests again next week with the uh next Holo Talk show which will begin on December 20th and run for uh uh the holiday week there so we'll have a guest coming on next week.
Other news um you may have been on the mailing list, you may not have been on the mailing list.
You know it's my style here at HoloTalk for the past uh two and a half years that I really don't sell anything on this show.
I basically just do the show.
Uh but I do I would like to announce that uh Sam Savage and I are now in production of our laser units and they are available, and this basically grew out of a request or a number of requests from different uh people involved with holography when we were working with our 35 milliwatt laser system that we put together and uh specifically the power drive unit that's uh hooked up to the Mitsubishi uh 35 milliwatt diode.
We got a number of emails uh from someone saying, if I paid you, would you put one of these together for me?
So we thought, you know, maybe we should build a few of these.
And uh as you know, if you're on the email list, we've been working on this for a while.
We have a number of different things available, a number of different options.
Uh I imagine there's four options really that you can choose from to uh have one of these inexpensive, relatively high power laser systems to do holography in your own uh holographic studio or lab.
Um we have a web page up now, DNS Lasers.
We have uh someone working with us that's going to incorporate it, so we're going to be DNS Lasers Incorporated shortly.
But there's a few different options that you can order.
You can order the actual plans and schematic which you can build the system yourself.
Uh the schematic is to the uh power drive unit uh that you can put that together.
Uh there's another option is you can get the power drive unit and a separate chip that we have inside of that uh power drive unit to uh power the uh laser diode.
And you will need that chip with option one or option two, but with option two, you can order the chip with the uh with the plans at the same time.
With option one, you can order just the plans and then order the chip at a later time.
Option three is a complete kit.
Uh all of the components that you need, including the 35 millilatt Mitsubishi uh diode, uh, along with the barrel and the collimating optics and everything that you need to uh build the drive unit yourself.
Of course, option four is um the fact that you can buy the completely assembled unit where you take it out of the box and you're ready to shoot holograms uh right away.
So those things are available now, and I'm happy to be able to announce that.
I'm not going to be plugging this on each show, but uh I just wanted to remind everyone that uh you know we've been working on this for quite some time and we're happy to be able to bring this to you finally uh this week, and we do have quite a bit of uh interest in that.
If you're not on the email list, you can definitely get on that for uh further updates.
I spoke with um John Clare uh earlier.
Actually, I didn't speak with John Clayer, he sent me an email.
I asked him to give me an update on what he's doing with the uh uh multiple laser pointer uh holograms, and he's still experimenting uh with that, and he's had some very nice results using several laser pointers to create holograms where their power is combined and a hologram is shot from that.
Um what he's going to do now, he's moving off in the direction where he's going to buy raw diodes and uh attach the fiber directly either to the uh window itself on the diode or remove that window entirely and attach the fiber and uh have the uh laser light travel through the fiber in that way.
So we're looking for some uh very exciting stuff with the uh fiber optics and Steve Michael is working on uh fiber optic experiments as well and we will have uh further updates on that as uh time goes on uh on further holo talk shows.
Also Dave Hodges, Dave and I did speak today on the telephone for quite some time and Dave has had excellent results as he reported on the phone to me uh using the Slavic PFG oh three M holographic film.
And uh you'll remember that uh we spoke uh on uh several past Holo talk shows about uh using the PFG oh one uh which is a little bit more sensitive and and probably falls into uh the sensitivity range of the type of holography that amateur and hobbyists do because uh you know we're using relatively low power you're if you're using a pointer you're five milliwatts or below or even ten or fifteen milliwatts is uh fairly low power so the the PFG oh one certainly uh fits into that very nicely but uh what was really surprising about this is uh Dave Hodges was using the PFG 03M which is not as responsive.
It's uh it's uh usually we would think that uh the exposure times would be much too long uh for low power helium neon lasers to give good results on that but he said the uh the shots that he has done with that emulsion so far has been absolutely gorgeous.
Absolutely gorgeous.
And what's really very, very interesting about this is that uh he's working with uh five milliwatts in his uh studio uh uh which he has in his home and he eventually wants to do eight by ten so what he's doing with his experiments is he's taking the laser light and expanding that to an eight by ten area and then shooting four by five uh film uh in that eight by ten spread so uh basically what this gives him is an indication of how nice an eight by ten hologram would be without having to use the eight by ten film and uh he's just uh praising you know the results that he's had so far with this and he is using the uh let me check my notes here to make sure I have everything correct he is using the GP2 uh developing uh regimen which is available from both photographer's formulary and also Integraph and and of course the film is available from a number of locations as well um from integraph and from uh fourth dimension holographics and a number of different places but if you do go back to the link page that I have at HoloWorld you can get uh a listing of different um suppliers of that film as well and I would be interested to hear from anyone else who's using the uh PFG O3M because apparently it uh seems to be working out uh very well uh his exposure time he's saying is uh about ten times the exposure time of the PFG01 using the PFG03 and uh it doesn't seem to have that much of an effect, increasing that exposure time ten times for him.
So, uh maybe something to look at and he says the diffraction efficiency is so much higher.
The holograms are so bright, they exhibit so much depth.
Um that I I think this probably warrants, you know, uh further investigation and uh his development regimen uh he suggests that uh you do not excuse me, agitate the uh um the film in the developer.
Uh what he did was actually just drop the film into the development tray and leave it sit there undisturbed for fifteen minutes it took to develop it, uh in the uh GP two developer.
So uh that's a little update on that.
Um uh another possibility, uh, with a very high diffraction efficiency and very good results using low power, five milliwatts on the PFG O three M reported by uh Dave Hodges who's been working with that.
In fact, uh his results were from a laser spread that would have covered an eight by ten inch piece of film.
So, uh that's very encouraging.
Excuse me.
Uh not too much more news this week, so uh once again if you know uh of anyone who could uh send a few of the past Holo Talk shows uh to me, I would be very happy to receive them and get them up on the archive page so that others can enjoy uh some of the past shows and uh if I don't get a response from anyone and no one has the shows then that's that's it.
They're lost to history.
Unless uh someone out there has them and ha is not listening to the show this week, and maybe a few weeks or a few months down the line, um they would ask, you know, where are the shows?
And uh, oh, I have a couple of 'em, I can send them to you.
So we may not be at a total loss, but I'd appreciate it if anyone has a show to please email me.
Let me know what shows you have, and then I'll make arrangements to receive those shows and attach files to emails from you.
So once again, this is Frank Defraitas.
Thank you too for tuning in uh to another week of HoloTalk.
It was a short show and had some interesting news on here.
Um but we'll get back to our guests next week, and I look forward to continuing the broadcast well into the year 2000, uh bringing you news and information about the fields of lasers and holography.
So I will say have a great week.
And don't forget to tune in next week and every week to HoloTalk.
This is Frank Defraitas.
Take care.